what's up internet my name is Akash
Singh I'm on the flagrant 2 podcast I'm
also at Caroline's on Broadway Friday
and Saturday you as the Internet ask a
lot of dumb ass questions
and me as a comic has a lot of dumb ass
answers if you could have any one person
narrate do play-by-play of you having
sex who would it be oh my god if I had
self-confidence I would say Chuck
Charles Barkley just because I know it'd
be hilarious
but I don't have any confidence in my
dick game in particular so I'm trying to
think of who would be nice I think Ernie
Johnson I hate to keep it on the same
set so let me move that let me go Kenny
main Kenny man got a nice dry sense of
humor she'll probably be too involved
thinking about how I'm not making her
come to realize the jokes he's making
and then later on should be like oh that
was funny and then the experience me
semi satisfying
you get to marry the girl of your dreams
but you have to watch your biggest enemy
have sex with her first do you do it let
me tell you I'm with a girl I love with
all my heart and no absolutely not my
worst enemy cannot have sex with my girl
I'll kill both of them if you could only
watch one category of porn for the rest
of your life what would it be oh boy
it's a toss-up between barely legal and
milf because I just want new people
coming into the pipeline you know what I
mean and those are the tubes so
depending on where my issues lay
probably barely legal I I have to say it
barely though it's barely remember that
word is barely if you could wipe one
group of people off the earth who would
it be they'll black no I'm kidding ah no
but seriously Chinese people again
kidding actually you've been to China
one group of people off the earth who
would it be top of mind because we just
talked about it people who watch
documentaries and then they pretend they
know something because they watched a
documentary you don't know anything read
a book if you have the flexibility to
blow yourself would you ever what if
everybody knew you did honestly
I might answer this differently but I
know a guy Matthew Broussard funny comic
who can blow himself and she said he did
it no you can bring him on have him talk
about it and he said he said the truest
sentence I think that's ever been spoken
on earth he said blowing yourself feels
a lot more like sucking your dick
than getting your dick sucked so no
thank you
[Laughter]
if you are in an open field armed with a
baseball bat how many 10 year-olds
wearing bike helmets could you take down
before they got you a hundred I'll beat
the [ __ ] I ate ten year old on earth
right now I'll take out ten bare
knuckles and I got small hands no
problem if every time you finished sex a
song played which song would you want it
to be I believe I can fly
[Laughter]
30 minutes Russell Lyon who wins holy
[ __ ] are midgets like retards and their
unnaturally strong because if so give me
the midgets but if not tyrion lanister
finally getting got are you unnaturally
strong I had a real okay all right a
little uncomfortable
Oh we'll apologize when the camera stops
recording if you could live anyone's
life with anyone's body who would it be
oh my god who's [ __ ] the hottest girl
that I know I don't want to say Colin
Jost that's that's not know never mind
who's the second hottest girl you know
Pete Davidson
honey Pete Davidson for a day well
apparently Pete Davidson's gets all
these hot girls who got a huge as dick
and it'd be nice to know that feels like
so there you go would you rather be the
president the Pope or the ruler of North
Korea I think I'm ready be the ruler all
right like I
I give you gotta be one president that's
a lot of stress people judging you Pope
all your employees [ __ ] kids you got
to deal with that stress ruler North
Korea do whatever you want man nobody
telling nothing whatever you want if you
could pick one person from TV movies to
be your college roommate who would you
pick I hate to be unoriginal my gonna
say Charles Barkley again let me not say
that let me snot say that Dave Chappelle
Dave Chappelle would be fun I'd be a fun
time
you haven't seen you Chappelle you
should pull out whoa you don't care
about poor people finally open it thank
God poor people in midgets all right who
needs them thank God her son left all
right
if you could bring back one person from
the dead who would it be
as an Indian I'm required to say Gandhi
I can't have fun with this answer I'm
sorry the black person guys ain't more
than with the king or some other little
person that he really admires yeah
really killed two quotas in one person
huh they got a [ __ ] he is affirmative
squared action if you could party with
one sports team in history who would it
be
I'm from Dallas the 92-93 Cowboys with
the White House and cocaine and hos
running it out of there that's a party
magic you love to party with the 80s
Lakers but there's consequences there
potentially you know what I mean 90s
Cowboys you walk out all right would you
would you rather watch your dad have sex
with a 100 year old man or watch your
mom kill so much who's the 100 year old
man is it George Burns cuz I'll do that
would you rather watch your dad have sex
with a hundred-year-old man in a nursing
home or watch your mom kill someone
maybe I learn something from my dad you
know what I mean I can't watch my mom do
that to somebody I can't watch my dad do
that to somebody
thank you so much man
you